welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I am Priyanka and I'm
Jenny and in this episode we'll be
making a loaf of gluten-free bread yes
we will there's a lot going on in this
recipe that we will need to pay
attention to keeping ingredients
separate from the allergens keeping
ingredients separate from each other and
making sure our space is allergen-free
much like with cloud security we need to
keep things safe from external threats
and even from mixing internally before
it's appropriate
[Music]
dinar winner is an application that
collects recipe submissions from users
all over the world and post regular
winning recipes for everyone to enjoy
the recipe submissions need to be
assessed for clarity and then scrubbed
for any identifiable information before
they are sent on to judging the
anonymous judging takes place after
which winners are contacted and their
recipes are posted to the application
submitted recipes can't mix with
reviewed recipes due to the potential
private information from contestants so
it's critical to uphold that separation
just like with creating gluten-free
recipes it's important to not only have
gluten-free ingredients but a
gluten-free space as well exactly our
recipe is simple but this situation is
complicated and for dinner winner due to
the high number of submission that's a
lot to handle do we need a dedicated
facility or just a strict cleaning
policy well it depends let's see how
their system works today during the
competition times users upload their
recipe in the text format these recipes
get stored in blob storage from where
they're pretty manually checked for
private information like emails and
phone numbers of participants this
private information is then removed
before sending to the judges to would
the winning recipe that makes it on the
platform for everyone to see the problem
with it
well there's a lot of problems with this
arrangement one because this is a manual
process with a ton of volume this system
will scale badly but the biggest problem
here is security it's difficult to know
what's been reviewed and what's been
updated and what still has private
information in it what if just one
recipe submission gets accidently shared
with the judges with the contestants
name and contact information this will
potentially make the contest unfair and
can lead to brand damage for dinner
winner what sounds like a losing
situation and since dinner loser doesn't
have the same ring to it let's make sure
they can keep their recipes clean of
personal information just as we need to
keep this surface clean of gluten just
like dinner winner in every organization
data protection officers like you face
an ever increasing amount of data data
that must be protected and treated
appropriately quarantine and classifying
that data can be
complicated and time-consuming specially
given hundreds or thousands of files a
day and what if you could take each file
upload it to a quarantine location and
have it automatically classified and
then moved to the appropriate location
based on the classification result in
the next few episodes we will show you
how to implement such a system by using
cloud functions cloud storage and the
cloud data loss prevention API dinner
winner needs an automated process for
sorting submissions and categorizing
reviewed submissions the ingredients
appengine for front-end Google Cloud
storage to store recipe submission files
pops up for messaging cloud functions
for some quick automation in surrealist
fashion and the most important
ingredient DLP api to detect private
information now let's put this all
together and stir it up let's say the
front-end is an app engine where the
user submits the recipe the user would
upload the text file including the
recipe and info types like the name date
email and phone numbers in the web
interface the uploaded file is sent to
Google Cloud Storage this triggers a
cloud function to create the data loss
prevention job in pub/sub once the event
is received by pub/sub it triggers
another cloud function which calls the
DLP API and looks for the confidential
information in the recipe files once
found it moves a file to a separate
storage bucket if the file does not
contain any confidential information
like the info types email address phone
number then the function moves it to
another bucket
this request flow keeps the confidential
data separate from the non confidential
and is fairly automated such that as
soon as the file hits the cloud storage
bucket all other processes kick off
automatically to protect the data now
that we understand the problem and the
use case we know exactly what needs to
be done to implement this solution and
next week we'll reveal our step by step
plan for dinner winner and maybe we'll
even get to that gluten-free bread
yep but first we will need to avoid
cross contamination by deep cleaning the
kitchen and since get cleaning with
cloud isn't quite what we're going for
it we've got some behind-the-scenes work
to do while we're at it don't forget to
give us a like comment and subscribe to
learn what you can cook up with the
cloud
[Music]